Narrator: THE CHINESE BUILT
A VAST STRUCTURE
USING BILLIONS OF TONS
OF SOLID STONE AND BRICKS.
IT SAT ON A STURDY FOUNDATION
OF HUGE GRANITE BLOCKS.
SMOOTH BRICKS MADE
THE SHEER WALLS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO SCALE.
EMBATTLEMENTS PROTECTED
THE DEFENDERS AT THE TOP.
RUBBLE WAS CRAMMED
BETWEEN THE BRICK FACES
TO CREATE A STABLE CORE.
AND SMOOTH STONES PAVED THE TOP.
NEARLY 23 FEET HIGH
AND OVER 16 FEET THICK,
THIS WALL WAS IMPENETRABLE.
WHENEVER VISITORS
REACH THE WALL,
THEY ALWAYS TEND TO ASK
THE SAME QUESTIONS.
AND ONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS IS,
WHY IS THE WALL HERE
AND NOT OVER THERE
OR OVER HERE?
Narrator: WILLIAM STUDIES
THE LANDSCAPE AROUND
THE GREAT WALL TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THE CHINESE BUILT
WHERE THEY DID.
Lindesay: FROM THE TOP
OF THIS WATCH TOWER,
I CAN SEE PRECISELY
WHY THE WALL IS HERE.
DOWN HERE, LOW GROUND,
ASCENDING, ASCENDING,
AND THIS IS THE PEAK.
AND THE WALL IS TAKING
THAT PEAK LINE
TO THE PEAK OVER THERE.
I MOVE TO THE RIGHT,
AND THE WALL DESCENDS.
LEVEL OF THE MOUNTAINS
FALLS AWAY DRAMATICALLY.
THIS IS THE ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT LINE
FOR THIS SECTION OF WALL.
Narrator: THE WALL'S BUILDERS
FOLLOWED THE HIGH GROUND,
BUT THEIR PATH WAS NEVER
A SIMPLE, STRAIGHT LINE.
Lindesay: INITIALLY, I COULDN'T
SEE ANY LOGIC
IN THAT SEEMINGLY HAPHAZARD
ROUTE THAT THE WALL TOOK.
BUT ACTUALLY,
ALL OF THESE TWISTS
AND TURNS, I BELIEVE,
ARE FOR A PURPOSE.
IT IMPROVED THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
IN TERMS OF LINES OF FIRE.
NOT ONLY IN THE FACES
OF THE ENEMY,
BUT FROM THE SIDE.
Narrator:
THE CHINESE BUILT THE GREAT WALL
TO FOLLOW THE TERRAIN,
RISING 4,921 FEET
TO THE TOPS OF MOUNTAINS.
THEY POSITIONED WATCH TOWERS
492 FEET APART
TO MAXIMIZE THEIR KILL ZONES.
AND CLEARED THE TREES
FOR TWO MILES
SO RAIDERS WERE IN CLEAR VIEW.
SPURS EXTENDED THE LINE OF SIGHT
TO GUARD AGAINST ATTACKS.
Lindesay:
NO ENEMY IN THEIR RIGHT MIND
WOULD WANT TO FIGHT
WITH THE CHINESE RIGHT HERE.